I would like to share one idea about
managing water scarcity for food
security focusing on sub-saharan Africa
the world's population has been
increasing continuously and this has
been translated into more mouse for food
and agriculture and food production
needs a lot of water actually right now
just for irrigation itself use about
seventy percent of further withdrawn
water resources and as a consequence
many rivers and lakes are drying up so
we are facing great challenge to produce
more food with the limited water
resources then the question is where we
should focus on to produce more food
with per drop of water food production
is not just for local consumption it is
also for international trade at the
moment the international traded food
accounts for about fifteen percent of
the total production an international
trade that carries virtual water which
is the water used there for production
during the production America North
America and South America and Oceania
are the major food exporters and also
the virtual water exporters and Asia and
Africa are the major importers of food
also the importance of were taught in
this map of water scarcity as you can
see a tree though major water scarce
regions are in the middle latitude of
northern hemisphere and the in
sub-sahara Africa there isn't physical
water scarcity however in sub-saharan
Africa yield crop yield is very low
typically one-third of the global
average and why it is that we did a lot
of studies on the factors influencing
the
yield growth in sub-saharan Africa and
craft models are widely used for this
kind of an investigation and coupling it
with GIS we can do large-scale
assimilation and find out what factors
are important for crop growth this slide
actually shows one of our research
result which is simulated a result of
amazed yield in sub-saharan Africa the
total height shows the range of the year
the red line shows the average yield of
maize at this moment for the whole
continent and then the second bar
actually shows if we increase the water
supply to meet the demand for by the
crops what will happen it shows actually
it doesn't have much impact on you
because you doesn't increase much the
third part actually shows when we
increase the fertilizer fertilizer
supply to meet the demand of crops and
then you can see the huge jumps by a big
margin but the ranch is still very large
because this means that the the ranch or
the yield is unstable and the last one
last bite ratio said that the yield is
stable with water supply and sufficient
fertilization and here we want to show
the technology and and know-how actually
there we know how to improve the yield
for sub-saharan Africa if we can double
the yield then the sub-saharan Africa
would not need to import cereal anymore
if we contribute then there will be
surplus for export so with many regions
in the world having water scarcity and
the increasing production becomes a more
costly and sub-saharan Africa is
new sauce for the future food supply and
virtual water supply to elevate water
scarcity other regions so a Chinese
entrepreneur once has said give me a
Africa and I can feed the world he's
wrong he cannot have Africa but he's
right in a way that Africa does have two
big potential to provide food to the
world and the challenge is how to
unleash this potential in our
sustainable and equitable and
economically way
you